jusqu'au 24 octobre c'est la semaine de
la science histoire de susciter des
vocations scientifiques et d'accroître
l'intérêt du public pour tous les
domaines de recherche de mille 200
manifestations sont prévues alors dans
le domaine de l'infiniment petit notre
curiosité était attiré par la
réalisation d'un laboratoire du
commissariat à l'énergie atomique qui
vient de mettre au point le plus petit
transistor du monde il s'agit d'une puce
une toute petite puce vraiment tout
petit et qui a besoin de rester très
propre comme l'indiquent jean-claude
allanic et claude sicard l'ennemi des
puces c'est la poussière
l'hygiène est ici encore plus
draconiennes que dans une salle
d'opération
alors avant de découvrir le plus petit
transistor du monde conçu dans ce
laboratoire de grenoble il faut
commencer par se débarrasser de toutes
traces de particules polluantes
c'est là dans cette salle où même la
lumière est étudiée que les chercheurs
du cea ont réussi l'exploit fabriquer un
transistor de 20 nanomètres 20
millionième de millimètre à l'anneau m
c'est l'équivalent d'un cheveu dans un
terrain de football
d'ailleurs faut utiliser un microscope
électronique à balayage qui grossit
jusqu'à 100000 fois pour voir un
transistor ouvriers sur cette image gros
si cette fois-ci 500 mille fois voici le
coeur du nouveau transistor
il est capable de traiter des dizaines
de milliards d'informations à la seconde
tout en étant dix fois plus petit que
tout ce qui existe déjà entre et les
plaques de silicium dans des équipements
entièrement automatisés
dans lesquels des robots ont manipulé
les plaquettes n'y a pas d'intervention
humaine
reste à passer de l'exploit en
laboratoire à la phase industrielle
cela devrait prendre encore une
quinzaine d'années mais les applications
seront alors très concrètes avait donc
là une carte de téléphone portable sur
lequel il y a plusieurs cercles intégré
dans chaque set peut intégrer il ya des
centaines de millions de transistors
si nous arrivons à faire les transistors
plus petits nous pourrons regrouper tous
ses circuits intégrés dans toutes ses
fonctions sur un seul circuit intégré
une miniaturisation qui permettrait par
exemple de stocker dans une goutte d'eau
l'équivalent d'un milliard de pages
autrement dit tous les livres de la
bibliothèque nationale